المحققون محظوظون
لأن لديهم الكثير من
مقاطع فيديو المراقبة التي يمكنهم
تمشيطها نظرًا لموقع هذه
الحادثة المثير للاهتمام، أعني إذا فعلت
أي شيء عند أي من نقاط التفتيش هذه
قادمة من جانبي الجسر أه،
فيديو المراقبة هو  وفيرة وعالية
الجودة، لكن أفضل مقطع فيديو
شاهدناه حتى الآن يأتي من إحدى
نقاط التفتيش ولكنه في الأساس
خارج الكاميرا تقريبًا، إنه مقطع
فيديو ستشاهده قريبًا
حيث يمكنك رؤية نوع السيارة في
أعلى اليسار أه الجانب الأيمن العلوي
من الشاشة يتحرك
بسرعة عالية ويمر فوق ذلك الجدار
ثم ترى هذا الانفجار أه
بعد ذلك أه ولكن هذا على
طريق محلي على الجانب الأمريكي من الحدود وهو
طريق  حيث إذا كنت على هذا الطريق
فأنت غير ملتزم بالعبور إلى
كندا